and suppose he's been in politics longer
than a lot of people watching this show
right now have been alive and somehow
she will end up super rich how'd that
happen she's now one of the wealthiest
members of congress and just last year
apparently pelosi's personal wealth grew
by almost 17 million dollars to yours
actually millions of americans are
forced into poverty by the coronal
lockdown she supported
so why are members of congress allowed
to trade in markets that they
effectively regulate
we don't know but we know for a fact
that nancy pelosi wants to continue
doing it she's defending it watch
madam speaker insider just completed a
five-month investigation finding that 49
members of congress and 182 senior
congressional staffers have violated the
stock app um the insider training law
i'm wondering if you have any reaction
to that and secondly should members of
congress and their spouses be banned
from trading individual stocks while
serving congress no i don't know to this
second one um
any we have a responsibility to report
in the stock
on the stock but i don't i'm not
familiar with that five month
review but if
people aren't reporting they should be
because this is a free market in people
we have a free market economy they
should be able to participate in that
we don't have a free market economy this
is not a free market this is insider
trading nobody cares like master cares
he's running for senate in the state of
arizona he's come out against this
promises to end it if elected he joins
us tonight blake masters thanks so much
for coming on how can this continue
well tucker it can't i mean naughty
nancy my goodness she's at it again
trading stocks breaking laws tucker i
think nancy pelosi is the poster child
for the rot and corruption in our
politics she uses her high office to
enrich herself right her husband they
make tens of millions of dollars every
year trading stocks look at her record
she's outperforming warren buffett she's
the best investor in the world
and how does that happen could it be
because she has non-public information
about these companies i mean this is
disgusting and i don't think we can
trust these people to regulate
themselves we can't trust them to police
themselves and so we just have to ban it
we need to ban individual congress
members from owning and trading stocks
it's just that simple
well it it kind of is that simple and if
you're nancy pelosi and you're already
one of the richest people in the country
and your speaker of the house at the age
of 81 what's what's kind of the point i
mean why wouldn't she just stop doing
this voluntarily what does that tell us
about her
well it tells us that she's really
corrupt and unfortunately the problem
goes so far deeper right it's not just
pelosi it's so many left-wing democrats
they're corrupt and they're hypocritical
so much so that there are terms for this
right champagne socialist
limousine liberal look at elizabeth
warren who's in the news this week for
attacking our country's richest
african-american
entrepreneur a successful businessman
who's on track to pay 12 billion dollars
in taxes this year yeah i'm talking
about elon musk of course and elon has
done more this week
for america
than elizabeth warren will do in her
lifetime and she has the nerve to
criticize him
so i'm just sick and tired of this and
if you're sick and tired of it you're
watching at home you're sick and tired
of the corruption in dc
help send me into the u.s senate go to
blakemasters.com donate as much as you
can to my campaign i promise you i will
put an end to this
yeah i mean well we're certainly really
quick i mean if she's getting better
returns than warren buffett is
is there some way for the rest of us to
benefit from her stock picking prowess i
mean she's a savant obviously she seems
like she's got dementia but no
how can we get how can she become our
cnbc anchor
oh my gosh well we do need to retire her
uh from her job i mean she's been in
office forever we need term limits we
need a new changing of the guard these
people are just so corrupt and tucker
i'm just so sick of it merry christmas
to everybody watching except you naughty
nancy a lump of coal for you
that's exactly right she's our jim
cramer blake masters running for the
united states senate in the state of
arizona a lot of people didn't think it
was in within reach of republicans the
polling is suggesting it is so thank you
we're rooting for you
thanks tucker hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else